like many traders that tell your market
for automatically voters in consumer
confidence and high income slip
but every day she comes here anyway
hoping that things will get better
yes things are tough but sitting at home
and doing nothing is not an option there
are so many mouths to feed
the opposition says the country is
adrift it blames Guinea's military
rulers saying they haven't charted a
clear course forward after seizing power
last year most guineans are caught in
the dispute between the country's
military leadership and the regional
block the economic community of West
African States and opposition demand for
a quick return to democracy prizes of
foodstuff have risen as unemployment has
grown well the price of bread increasing
by more than 30 percent in the past few
months
the biggest disappointment so far is
what activists call a lack of focus by
the military government
you can see they are simply groping in
the dark how can you explain that up to
now there's no clearly defined plan
where they want to go or who they are
carrying along they're just carrying on
as if the entire country is a military
Barrack it's a huge disappointment for
us
in one area however cool leader Mahmoud
has succeeded why predecessors failed
last month the trial opened in the
capital of the alleged masterminds of
the 2009 Stadium massacre in the capital
former president Musa Daddy's Kamara and
others appeared before a judge charged
with the killing of more than 150
protesters
whether the trial can draw the Public's
attention away from the economy remains
to be seen
Guinness Hunter has enjoyed some support
since last year's School
but as frustration with the lack of
progress in both politics and the
economy grows that support May soon turn
to anger on the streets Ahmad Idris
al-jazeera Conakry